pauvre europe ecologie les verts qui
pour le moment on refuse europe ecologie
les verts cette primaire il dit mais
cette idée elle est plutôt inspiré d'une
forme de désespoir que d'une forme de
dynamique justement est-ce qu'on en
parle et il entend les électeurs de
gauche il entend les électeurs de gauche
vous interpeller toutes et tous semaine
après semaine sur la situation à gauche
enfin s'il y avait un candidat ou une
candidate de gauche qui était encore une
fois loin devant si l'un d'entre eux
surpassait tous les autres et que une
dynamique se soient créés en faveur de
l'un ou de l'autre il est devant pour le
moment par exemple n'y a pas un candidat
qui est au-dessus de 10% y'a pas un
candidat de gauche qui pour l'instant se
qualifie pour le deuxième tour et on va
les bras ballants observé ça jusqu'à
quand donc oui il fallait faire
mouvement oui il fallait prendre acte de
cette situation est elle en
responsabilité elle dit à l'ensemble de
celles et ceux qui veulent participer la
gauche a encore quelque chose à dire
dans ce pays enfin quand même face à
l'explosion des inégalités face à cette
question climatique fasse ou défi du
grand âge est ce que la face à la
situation de l'hôpital public au
lendemain de cette crise sanitaire n'est
pas l'homme ni la gauche n'arrive pas à
les porter ces questions mais quel est
le candidat de gauche aujourd'hui qui
arrive à mettre ces questions là dans le
débat c'est bien parce qu'il y a cette
extrême
dispersion émiettement de la gauche que
aucun des candidats gauche aujourd'hui
et bien ne vous savez c'est un ami qui
nous écoutent
[Musique]